vous étiez tout seul avec un ami j'étais
avec un ami et on rejoignait un autre
ami d'accord vous étiez trois donc au
début 2 puis 3 oui d'accord ça c'est pas
le problème donc un bar voilà tout un
bar sympa voilà vous y allez et très
sympa enfin c'est ce qu'on m'avait dit
je connaissais pas d'accord en plus un
nouveau spot toujours voilà exactement
voilà d'accord donc c'est la première
fois que vous y allez comme vous l'avez
dit et vous avez senti une animosité dès
votre arrivée ou pas du tout pas du tout
donc je suis arrivé je suis tombé sur un
jeune homme qui m'a dit je viens en ami
on peut faire un selfie plutôt très
sympa et après bah au moment on s'est
dit on est dans un bar on va les
commander un verre adhérent et là
généralement c'est le principe c'est un
peu le principe donc on va vers le bas
et là
c'est marrant parce que j'ai
l'impression de raconter la faire du
siècle alors qu'en fait c'est
intéressant alors je te le dis non non
je raconte quand même l'histoire parce
que vous l'avez fait de la médiatiser tu
veux que j'appelle Michel Marie
il est environ une heure 50
[Applaudissements]
Florian Philippot arrive dans un bar
il commande un des cocktails du bar
nommé le papayou Lele sans alcool
[Applaudissements]
il a le serveur lui sert un
papaoutai
il est malentendu là la situation
s'envenime
donc là on commence et là le serveur se
tourne je pensais qu'il allait préparer
le verre et se retourne vers moi il dit
en fait je suis en désaccord total avec
vos idées politiques donc je ne vous
servirai pas
alors j'ai même cru mal comprendre parce
qu'en fait ça m'est juste jamais arrivé
en dizaine d'années de vie politique
publique ça ne m'était jamais arrivé
alors je dis pardon est-ce que vous
pouvez répéter il répète et je lui dis
mais je comprends pas c'est totalement
illégal ça s'appelle un refus de vente
et de la discrimination et il me dit oui
je sais alors je lui dis bah écoutez je
pars principes je vais appeler la police
ce que je ne fais jamais dans ma vie
j'ai dû porter plainte peut-être deux ou
trois fois au total
et j'ai dit mais là c'est juste pas
possible et donc j'appelle ils sont
arrivés un petit peu après
et voilà et je sais qu'effectivement
ensuite son patron est arrivé là un peu
engueulé derrière j'entendais
et il est le patron est revenu vers moi
là il m'aurait dit il m'a écouté désolé
mon serveur a déconné prenons un verre
j'étais terminé mais non il viendra il
dit non non c'est pas du tout ça en fait
qui ce qu'il voulait dire oui on
n'aurait pas dû faire ça mais ce qu'il
voulait dire c'est que c'était pour
votre bien pour votre sécurité parce que
nous ne sommes pas en capacité d'assurer
votre sécurité donc on peut pas vous
servir
j'ai qu'est-ce que vous racontez d'abord
je me sens très en sécurité il y a aucun
problème si je ne l'étais pas chez parti
j'ai dit de me dites pas ça alors qu'il
m'a dit l'inverse il m'a dit autre chose
me prenez pas en plus pour un idiot quoi
c'est tout voilà donc c'est pas plus que
ça mais à ce moment-là
j'ai décidé effectivement de porter
plainte parce que je suis choqué par
toute discrimination
je suis très sensible à ce sujet parce
que j'ai organisé pendant deux ans des
manifs sur les discriminations très
graves qui sont celles du Pass sanitaire
et du Pass vaccinal et celle des
suspendus qui ont perdu leur boulot
parce qu'ils se sont pas fait injecter
un produit et donc ce sujet des
discriminations moi il me tient
extrêmement à cœur
et donc voilà j'ai pas voulu laisser
passer ça maintenant je le dis si ce
serveur se gène Server m'appelle ou bien
me voir je sais pas et me dit je
m'excuse
très bien si présente des excuses
sincères et qui me dit bah je referai
plus jamais de discrimination ainsi moi
je retire immédiatement ma plante il y a
aucune problème alors je lui conseille
fortement effectivement le présenter les
excuses parce que la police a pris ça
très au sérieux il a déjà été entendu
au commissariat central de Paris il sera
convoqué ultérieurement et il faut
savoir qu'on est en plein j'ai regardé
le code on essaie de la discrimination
en raison des opinions politiques avec
refus d'un service dans un lieu qui
accueille de public 50 prisons et risque
prisons 75000 €. si vous appelle vous
oubliez tout là il vaut mieux pour lui
il vaut mieux pour lui qu'il reste ça
très vite parce qu'effectivement je me
suis renseigné vous n'avez pas causé de
trouble c'est un bar voilà c'est un bar
qui est quand même assez surveillé il y
a du personnel donc il y avait pas de
risque que des gens s'en prennent à vous
même dérangé par vos opinions vous étiez
calme donc là on est en plein dans de la
discrimination moi je défends je lutte
contre toutes les discriminations il
faut lutter contre celle-là aussi voilà
absolument d'ailleurs dans un instant
les chirurgences avec nous puisqu'on
aura Francis qui sera avec nous Francis
à qui il est arrivé
mal aventurière puisqu'il avait commandé
au distributeur un tweet c'est qu'il a
reçu un Balisto en
je vais même dire autre chose parce que
vous moi je n'ai pas donné publiquement
le nom du non du truc je le donnerai pas
été convoqué de l'établissement il y a
un média qui a donné je sais pas par
mégarde le nom d'établissement
aujourd'hui donc il y a des gens qui
savent je dise lance un appel ne n'en
voulait pas à cet établissement
soyez courtois soyez bienveillant il y a
eu un souci qui me regarde on va le
régler tranquillement mais n'en voulait
pas c'était établissement il ne faites
rien contre lui franchement c'est bien
de votre part parce que moi aussi j'ai
consulté tout ce qui s'est passé après
le le l'incident il a déjà des appels à
niallons pas bien sûr pas sympa c'est
inadmissible etc donc il faut mieux
c'est bien qu'il soit venu ça c'est très
bien il faut calmer le jeu parce que
c'est un bar voilà il y a eu un souci
mais voilà